body tracers are one of the most popular
types of poy tricks with eye-catching
options ranging from snakes to tuck
turns and many more in this video I'm
going to take you through five skill
levels of body tracers to help you find
an option that fits where you are in
your POI journey and give you new
challenges to explore in the
future Drex here from Drex Factor p
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain with a video exploring
the many amazing directions that PO body
tracers can take you in but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys pyrro ter light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
becklen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission body tracers emerged from
relative obscurity to become one of the
most recognizable and widespread
families of petrix out there thanks to
the groundbreaking work of artists like
Thomas nasol Johansson Leo aaza UDA
imamura and Ivan Mel gorinov body
tracers have become a Mainstay of the PO
world and a favorite for many in it I've
covered the topic in some detail before
with everything from Individual trick
tutorials to a full history of the term
but one thing I haven't done yet is
offer up a road map for people to get
into body tracers and challenge
themselves by seeing what options still
lie ahead of them so regardless of
whether you're an absolute beginner or
you've been spinning for multiple years
I've got a trick on this list that is
sure to give you a new challenge let's
dive
in trick number one beginner tuck turns
tuck turns are among the first poy
tricks that many flow artists learned
and I've long maintained that they're
also a hidden body Tracer and not only
that we constantly underestimate just
how useful they are you can perform tuck
turns by spinning the PO in a small
pedal behind your shoulders and hips as
you take your hands around in a circle
generally we first learn this in
together times same direction and
there's a lot going on under the hood
here tuck turns can be thought of as two
petal inpin flowers that we wrap around
our shoulders and hips adding more body
interaction to what's otherwise a pretty
stock flower but the rabbit hole doesn't
end there if I flatten down the path of
the hands to just a straight line it
suddenly becomes very easy to see that
tuck turns are A variation on pois
snakes a popular form of body tracing
this also means that we can take the
tuck turn into horizontal or vertical
snake variations or explore volume with
it in a variety of different ways and
recognizing that these tuck turns
represent a POI body Tracer done in one
specific timing and Direction mode also
means that we have three other options
for this move that we can explore I'm a
particular fan of the split time
opposites version but tuck turns are not
the only beginner poy tricks that offer
up body Tracer variations and for our
next trick on the list we're going to
explore another one trick number two
beginner intermediate Archer
fountains the PO 3B weave is perhaps the
most famous po move of all time but its
Simplicity obscures a wide variety of
fun variations the most important
variation for our list though is the
variation known as the Archer weave this
involves extending one of the hands far
out away from the performer in wall
plane and keeping the other hand close
to the opposite shoulder resulting in a
pose not unlike an Archer drawing the
string of a bow but getting down the
Archer weave is only the first step to
getting down this unique body tracing
variation after all we can use the 3B
weave to turn in Waist straps and expand
those waist straps out to fountains and
the same is true of Archer leaves Archer
fountains take the fountain concept and
make it sleek and sensual in a way that
no other Fountain can touch this
requires us to slide our hands up and
down each arm as we go above our heads
and below our shoulders the result is
perhaps my favorite body Tracer of all
time even better when we recognize that
we usually perform fountains in an inpin
direction that also gives us access to
performing them in an anti-spin
Direction too and the anti-spin Archer
Fountain is easily the coolest
expression of this concept with our tuck
turns and weaves down it's time to get
into some more intermediate level tricks
and specifically apply the body Tracer
label to some po flowers and
hybrids trick number three intermediate
the
nasol it's rare that a pyri becomes so
identified with a specific performer as
to get named after them but Thomas nasol
Johansson is no ordinary performer one
of the most accomplished and stylish po
Spinners to emerge from Sweden during
the height of the Techo movement neol
made significant contributions to
popular moves like stall trasers and
body tracers but this move is perhaps
his most famous contribution of all when
we get right down to it the neol is
really just a poy hybrid a four pedal
anti-spin flow combined with a two-
petal inpin flower a hybrid that is one
of the most popular in the world and for
which there are countless variations but
there's something unique about the
version nasol popularized the ways in
which it wraps around the body bring to
mind crossers and windmills but more
than that it just makes this hybrid pop
in a way that no other variation
can even better it combines seamlessly
with the Archer Fountain we described in
our last section to create a slick combo
that moves back and forth between the
two tricks try this one out once you
have both tricks down and give your
audience a taste of two body tracers
that fit together smooth as butter if
you found the nasol to be a fun
challenge then the next item on the list
will take you even further further into
body tracing flower Bliss trick number
four intermediate Advanced Mel's body
Tracer here we have another entry on the
list that is so associated with a
specific po spinner style that it's hard
to describe it without including their
name in the conversation Ivan Mel
goranov is a Russian poy spinner who has
made countless contributions to the poy
world over the course of the past decade
but one of his more commonly perform
tricks is this split time opposites
variation that goes around his shoulders
as he works from side to side
incorporating elements of crossers and
flowers this body Tracer is a fun
challenge if You' gotten to the point
where simply doing the reels around your
body parts has become second nature put
those skills to the test with this
unique trick you can take this body
Tracer from side to side or up and down
depending upon what flavor you're most
interested in exploring there's no wrong
answer here this is also a great
opportunity to point you towards Mel's
Channel where he frequently uploads
combo challenges and New Tricks
including combos that frequently feature
this one check out the link down in the
description to learn more now before I
share with you my final pick for five
levels of Po body tracing I do have a
quick favor to ask if you've come this
far it seems likely that you have an
interest in POI and flow arts and if
that's the case then I can help you
learn more make sure to subscribe and
ring the bell so you know exactly when I
drop a new video plus which it helps
other people find the channel thanks so
much now to cap off our list with trick
number five advanced folding
lines this may seem like an odd pick why
is there a contact pyric on this list
well it's because it requires knowledge
of body tracing to get it down folding
lines involve rolling the poy head from
the hand to the elbow and then back out
again as the hand folds back and forth
in front of our body hence the name but
what's going on under the hood here is
something we've been looking at since
our very first trick on this list namely
the path that the poy handle takes
during this roll is identical to the
movement of the the PO head when we do a
tuck turn or a snake we've just switched
which end of the prop happens to be
touching our body this means that it can
actually be helpful to get in-depth
knowledge of body tracers in order to
get folding lines down it's a spot where
cross trainining can be helpful for
learning more about two branches of the
PO world that otherwise seem very
different and distinct try out this
trick for yourself with this knowledge
in mind and see if it helps you
visualize where you need the tether to
go as you perform this trick I know that
it helped me out when I was first
learning it want to learn how to do all
the tricks on this list I'll include
links to tutorials for them down in the
description of this video but for now I
hope you enjoyed this list and found an
option that's right for you wherever you
are with your own skills which body
tracers would make your list did I miss
a favorite leave me a comment and let me
know which one and what tricks you'd
like to see me break down by skill level
next
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I want to give a shout out to
my flow patrons that are listed up on
screen y'all rock thanks so much for
making this video and all the videos on
my channel possible and if you out there
watching aren't currently a supporter
but you still love the work that I do
I'd love to invite you to help me out by
checking out my patreon over at
patreon.com drexfactor to and signing up
if you like what you see I've got a
whole host of awesome rewards available
but more important than that you'll be
supporting my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you if you dug this video and
you'd like to check out even more
variations on those tuck turns I was
showing off earlier I did a video on
five levels of Tuck turns that I'll link
to down in the description as well as up
on screen check it out and see if it
gives you any more ideas either way
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace